i i have uh tentatively
titled in my own head this section
jumping the shark with the new england
journal of medicine
so um new england journal of medicine
i'll just start with their tweet because
why not why not go there
new england journal of medicine said
here's zach
sex designations on birth certificates
offer no clinical utility
and they can be harmful for intersex and
transgender people moving such
designations below the line of
demarcation would not compromise the
birth certificate's public health
function
but could avoid harm okay
they link in that tweet to their newly
published paper
which is here failed assignments
rethinking sex designations on birth
certificates
uh here hold on a second let me go to
this is the paper
uh in a pdf form so okay
um the first paragraph of this paper
which was just published
three day two days ago failed
assignments rethinking sex designations
on birth certificates in 1900
the year the u.s census bureau created
the first iteration of the u.s birth
certificate
nearly all works occurred at home often
attended by family members and midwives
without specialized training
during the 20th century as the medical
profession assumed greater
responsibility for managing childbirth
it also assumed responsibility for
completing birth certificates
a process that includes a medical
evaluation to categorize each newborn as
male or female
we believe that it is now time to update
the practice of designating sex on birth
certificates given the particularly
harmful effects
of such designations on intersex and
transgender
people so um
i am going to argue
that failing to include sex on board
certificates and they do specify they
want to
move it below what is called the line of
demarcation which means that it is not
available
as a public part of your uh birth
certificate and it is still available as
like aggregate
data for statistical use but it's not
part of your
your your id um
that in fact doing so
doing this will cause much greater harm
much greater confusion
societally but also much greater harm
mostly to women but also potentially to
men
because so much of our medical models
until recently have been based
on research on men and have assumed that
the male
model was the one that applied to
everyone and in fact we now know and
i'll provide
a ridiculous amount of evidence here
that
men and women have different outcomes
different etiologies different disease
progressions
for so many conditions that if we
start pretending at the level of birth
that this is not true
we are going to cause a tremendous
amount of harm
um all in service of a p of okay so
intersex is real
and there is potentially some real harm
done
by the misassignment of uh sex
on someone on a on the birth certificate
of someone who is in fact intersex
uh and trans is a muddier issue uh
but uh we will we will get back to that
so i want to read two more paragraphs
from this paper and
respond um respond to them one paragraph
designating sex as male or female on
birth certificates suggest that sex is
simple and binary when biologically it
is not
sex is a function of multiple biologic
processes with many resultant
combinations
about 1 in 5 000 people have intersex
variations as many as 1 in 100 people
exhibit chimerism
mosaicism or micromosaicism conditions
in which a person's cells may contain
varying sex chromosomes often
unbeknownst to them
the biologic processes responsible for
sex are incompletely defined and there
is no universally accepted test for
determining sex
wow that is so many numbers like i'm
super impressed with them aren't you
they used a lot of numbers
but like i got a few numbers too i got
some numbers
so we have been sexually reproducing
with two and only two sexes
uninterrupted for 500 million years
that's a conservative estimate you're
not talking about you and me you're
talking about
vertebrates that's like adaptive
immunity and sex
for sure have been in our lineage for
500 million years
uninterrupted but that's conservative
probably
sex with two and only two sexes goes
back one to two
billion years in our lineage to the
so-called lika
the last eukaryotic common ancestor
that's an acronym l-e-c-a
and maybe that's 1.2 billion maybe
that's as far back as 2 billion
but we're talking billions that's a lot
of zeros for you guys who are using all
these numbers and clearly don't know
what they mean
also we do have a universal way of
defining sex actually
apparently you haven't been thinking
very clearly about this it's called
gametes okay if you produce or could
or will or do or might have the
or have the machinery to produce gametes
that are tiny and zippy
you're male and if you produce or could
or will or do or have the machinery with
which to
maybe or will in the future or did in
the past produce gametes that are big
full of cytoplasm and stay still or
sessile
you're female simple right but that
didn't have very many numbers in it so
it's not very sciency is it
if it doesn't have numbers it's not
sciency so here's a couple more numbers
sex ratios return to one to one they do
there's a lot of math behind that i'm
not going to go there now but that means
with all due respect and recognition as
i already did
for the existence of intersex people and
who are very very very rare
and the also incredibly rare truly trans
people
roughly half of any population at any
moment is male and roughly half of any
population at any moment is
female sex differences manifest
in many places because as i already said
these most of most of what we have known
until recently
about medical processes and treatments
have been done on men
if you start confusing men with women
and vice versa and don't let it be clear
what you're going to have is a whole lot
of downstream health effects
mostly cascading to women's health so
here are just a few let me pull these up
so
here's the article you can just show my
screen throughout this sect
we have this article published in 2020
by the prestigious
new england journal of medicine here's a
2008 paper reviewing the sex differences
in alzheimer's disease not just in
progression but in etiology just in in
in symptomology and how it presents
here is a 2017 paper on sex differences
in the epidemiology clinical features
and pathos
physiology of migraine here's a 2000
here's a 2002 paper on the biological
basis of sex differences in
drug abuse here is a
let's see when is this where's the year
on this um
you can't find it 2013 a 2013 paper
on the sex differences in parkinson's
here's one from 2003 on sexual
dimorphism and asymmetries in the gray
white composition of the human cerebrum
that's
brain differences like actual anatomical
physical brain differences between men
and women
and here's one on the text emphasis is
fascinating
on the structural connectome of the
human brain that is to say the ways in
which the neurons are intersecting
connecting so
um there are no differences [ __ ]
this is ridiculous and like i cannot
believe
what is happening i cannot believe it i
was reading this paper and i said to you
i feel like
society has jumped the shark this is
completely insane okay one more
quotation yeah yeah one more question
from these people
assigning sex at birth also doesn't
capture the diversity of people's
experiences
about six in a thousand people identify
as transgender meaning their gender
identity doesn't match the sex they were
assigned at birth
others are non-binary meaning they don't
exclusively identify as a man or a woman
or gender non-conforming meaning their
behavior or appearance doesn't align
with social expectations for their
assigned sex
again i'm like so impressed with them
aren't you so impressed
babies have really amazingly diverse
experiences in utero don't they
and then of course the ones that they're
later gonna have all of that has to be
captured on the sex on the birth
certificate
i'm wondering too about those other
people who identify as different species
like the other kin
like they identify as elves or sea
snakes or something well in order to be
respectful
and fully inclusive of the other kin i
feel like
um we should put sea snake on their
birth certificate oh wait
actually we're doing something else
we're just taking human off of all of
our birth certificates we're now not
going to assume species
because some people are delusional and
think they're not human
that's not how this is supposed to work
what the hell is going on
well what the hell is going on first of
all i am
shocked to discover that birth
certificates do not capture the
whole experience that people have in
life i mean i know
they're defective documents clearly
totally shocked here's what i think is
actually going on
i think that there is actually a
central argument that can't be won and
must be won
for the trans activists to succeed right
so
you're talking about the trans rights
activists not the
different slightly overlapping
population of people who are actually
trans
right right exactly okay i think the
argument that
has to be won is that science
is supportive of their
position that there is no distinction
between
a woman who arises at womanhood through
regular developmental processes and one
who arises
there through transition okay so in
order to get there
they have to attack the sex is binary
and basically say science has concluded
otherwise
right and they are
muscling things like the new england
journal of medicine which we're going to
return in a later episode to
the corruption of science journals and
things but what you're effectively
seeing here
is that a corrupted science journal is
willing to go along with this nonsense
that anybody associated with this
journal should know better than
most of them will not understand that
the the game is not
chromosomes that it is in fact gametes
but nonetheless well it could be
corruption and it could be a form of
don't work
don't hurt me that's the same thing it's
so but
no i think i mean corruption corruption
is an umbrella category yes so there can
be multiple kinds of corruption and one
of them can be motivated by fear and
just like what i was calling the don't
hurt me walls that
that had all the black lives matter
stuff on them during the summer
um in store fronts lest they be
vandalized
this is kind of a don't hurt me article
okay any new england journal medicine
is playing by your rules please don't
come after us when we post something
that maybe you don't like
right um i mean corruption in the sense
of that file is corrupted
right there are many forces that distort
what you might find in the science
journal some of them you know you could
find
outright bribery you can find many
things that are shy of outright bribery
but function like it you can find
uh canonical ways in which it becomes
confused but the point is what you're
reading in there is and what it seems to
be
because it's been corrupted by some
force and here i want to try to draw out
the argument
okay the argument is
you will find in many of the things that
we are fighting over that you never
imagined we would have arguments about
there's a basic process
which is there are two polls having an
argument
and what they do is they stamp out the
space of nuance in between right so
you and i are trying to hash out an
argument that is in the space of nuance
in between
we do not deny that there are trans
people we do not deny that they have the
right to be treated as they would ask to
be treated for most intents and purposes
we do not believe that that should
extend to places where there's an
objective fact that requires
that you obscure it in order to do it so
this is a
or you put half the population at risk
by doing so right
we do not believe that you should assume
that you know
children who flirt with the idea that
they might prefer to be the other sex
actually are and all of these things so
anyway there's this inter
there's this space between these two
arguments
and the trans rights activists are
stamping it
out because the argument that sits there
is look intersex is real and it
is a physically measurable and studyable
phenomenon trans is real and it's not
the same thing as intersex it may have
some relationship to it but there's lots
of trans stuff that doesn't come down
to physiological intersexness what's
more
it appears to be ancient and widespread
many cultures have a version of trans
right
and so there is something in which you
can say look
trans is natural and to the extent that
there's any sort of
oppressive tendency to pretend it
doesn't exist or is
uh you know is necessarily about
something being broken
that's a bad argument however
trans is natural right it exists at some
level in many
populations maybe all of them what isn't
natural
is availing yourself of pharmaceuticals
and surgery and these other techniques
should you be allowed to i don't know
probably
but we do get to decide right if you
decide that you want to you know have
your arm removed and attached to your
ear
i don't think we let you do it right so
the point is it's not that you're
entitled to any modification of your
body you want
so to the extent that there is something
to be modified
then there's a question about whether or
not it is supported by the science and
so
in order to win that argument they have
to pretend that in fact
science invalidates the binariness
of sex and we all know it that's the
pretense right science invalidates the
binariness
and so they are going after this and you
know it's a silly hill for them to die
on because
you know no here let's let's see
let's say that we we played their game
yeah right and we just said you know
what
sex isn't real sorry we blew it uh we're
taking it off the birth certificates
we're going to just assume everybody is
uh is a blank until they tell us what
they are right
in that world some of them are sea
snakes
more power to them um uh
sn sea snakes by the crate all right oh
nice
nobody's gonna get it yeah but that's
those are the ones i like to give the
most points to oh
yeah i feel good about that um so
i've now lost my place and that's my
fault
um but uh here while you're coming up oh
do you get it well let's get us back
there but well so
uh i'm reminded that this is actually
the one year anniversary
of jk rowling's um descent into this
into this craziness in which she stands
up for
for reality she says dress however you
this is on twitter dress however you
please
call yourself whatever you like sleep
with any consenting adult who have you
live your best life and peace and
security but force women out of their
jobs for stating that sex is real
hashtag i stand with maya hashtag this
is not a drill
that's maya forstatter who was forced
out of her job
um for insisting that actually sex is
real
okay i got my place back excellent good
so let's say that we obliterate
sex we decide it's not real right and we
take the trans activists at their word
that they're as on board with science as
anybody and the science just doesn't
support a sexual binary
and so they're pro-science anti-sexual
binary because science supports them
right
so we move forward into the world we
obliterate all references to sex that
are not self-defined
right and we embrace science okay
science is going to rediscover the
awkward fact of sex
again and again and again because it's
so
very reliable right in other words in a
world where there was no sex
some bright graduate student is going to
come up with the idea
you know i wonder if um
somebody having a penis at birth is
predictive of the content of their cells
at any level i wonder if it's predictive
of their likelihood of getting
alzheimer's late in life i wonder if
it's
you know predictive of some feature of
parkinson's disease
so the point is you cannot get around
the fact
that of you know you can have a lot
noisier
correlations than you know than sex
and still have a valid pattern worth
describing right
sex is so low noise with respect to how
much variation
there is with respect to the basics that
it would be impossible not to
constantly be rediscovering it if you
just simply blindly point science at
interesting patterns everywhere
right you'll find sex like many times a
week
so so anyway i i think the point is look
[Laughter]
that was something like point sex at any
pattern and you'll find sex many times a
week
no point sorry point science at any
pattern uh blindly at any pattern and
you'll find sex many times a week many
times a week you'll keep rediscovering
yeah so anyway i think the point is look
they've just
they've chosen a hill to die on that
doesn't even exist
right either the point welcome to
post-modernity that's it
right either the science is
real and functions in the way we know
science does fallible but basically you
march in the direction of knowing more
over time
right in which case trans is natural
surgical alteration and puberty blockers
aren't
there's an incredibly strong tendency
having nothing to do with any
anyone you know designating somebody's
sex at birth
in which boys tend to grow up into men
and girls tend to grow up into women
right this is just this is the way
things
typically function that's not god i
thought it was god
[Laughter]
got a lot of ranting out here but i
think the point is look there's no hill
there
either well you're going up against like
i said this is the nature of
postmodernity it's like okay there's
this there's this hill that the
scientists that the
scientists are standing firm or standing
on going like sex is real hello sex is
real it's literally perhaps over a
billion years old i mean sex is over
billion years old but it may be over a
billion years old in our lineage alone
um and they are over here in flatland
or in a depression going like that's not
a hill those aren't hills
we're on a hill we got the hill we got
the hill and the hill just happens to
agree
with our idiosyncratic and
self-incompatible set of beliefs yeah
and oh by the way totally delusional
you